Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Benim çocukluğum,
İstanbul'da 80'li yıllarda
orta halli bir ailenin bilime
ve yeniliklere meraklı atmosferinde geçti.
O dönemde insanlığın
Dünya'nın keşfi ile ilgili
en çok merak ettiği şey,
uzaya çıkmaktı.
Biz bugün nasıl
gelecek senaryolarımızı yapay zekâ,
nesnelerin interneti, sürücüsüz araçlar
üzerine kurguluyorsak;
o dönemde en çok Dünya'dan çıkıp
evreni keşfetmek üzerine kurguluyorduk.
Evrende bizden başka canlı formu var mı,
çok merak ediyorduk.
Sıklıkla UFO haberleri çıkardı.
Dünya'nın sonunun
ya bir uzaylı istilası
ya da galaksi savaşları
ile geleceğini düşünüyorduk.
Sonra ilkokula başladım.
1. sınıf, 2. sınıf, 3. sınıf
derken fen bilgisi dersi ile tanıştım.
Birdenbire atmosferi keşfetmeye,
mevsimleri öğrenmeye,
canlı yaşamını anlamaya başladık.
Maddenin katı, sıvı, gaz hâli,
suyun döngüsü,
bitkilerin yaşamı...
Ve ben derste gördüğüm her şeyi,
günlük hayatımda da
gözlemlemeye başladım
ve Dünya ile aramda bir bağ kurdum.
Sonra ortaokul-lise yılları,
meslek seçimine sıra geldi
ve Dünya ile iç içe olabileceğim,
Dünya'nın iyiliği için çalışabileceğim
bir işim olsun istedim
ve çevre mühendisliğini seçtim.
İyi ki de öyle yapmışım.
O günlerden bugünlere
çok zaman geçti tabii.
Bugün teknoloji dediğimiz zaman
aklımıza çok başka şeyler geliyor
tabii ki ama,
insanlığın da uzayla ilgili merakı
bitmiş değil.
Sadece uzay çalışmalarının amacı değişti.
O dönemlerde biz
uzayda başka canlı var mı diye
merak ediyorduk, bunları araştırıyorduk.
Şimdi,
insan başka bir gezegende yaşayabilir mi,
bunu öğrenmeye çalışıyoruz.
Bu fotoğraf geçen sene
kasım ayında NASA'da çekildi.
Burada gördüğünüz NASA yetkilileri,
Mars'a gönderdikleri
Insight adlı uzay aracının
Mars yüzeyine
başarılı iniş yapmasını kutluyorlar.
Insight de bu.
Mars yüzeyinde ve yüzeyin altında
belli başlı araştırmalar yapmak için
oraya gönderildi.
Ayrıca Mars'a gönderilmiş ilk mekik değil.
Daha önce başka mekikler de gönderildi.
Şimdi size edinilen bilgiler ışığında,
Mars'la ilgili
bazı bilgiler vermek istiyorum.
Öncelikle:
Atmosfer
Mars'ın yoğunluğu
oldukça az bir atmosferi var
ve bu birçok şeye engel.
Örneğin,
Mars'ın bu az yoğun atmosferi
uzayın radyasyonundan
yüzeyde yaşayan kişileri koruyamayabilir.
Mesela biz Dünya'da
katman katman oldukça geniş,
yoğunluğu çok ideal
bir atmosferde yaşıyoruz.
Bu atmosferdeki katmanların;
bizi Güneş'in zararlı ışınlarından
korumak gibi,
Dünya'nın ısısını belli bir seviyede
tutmak gibi bazı görevleri var.
İnsanlık ileride bir gün Mars'a yerleşirse
o uzayın radyasyonundan korunmak için
bazı önlemler almak zorunda.
İkincisi:
Hava karışımı
Mars'a baktığınız zaman %95 oranında
karbondioksit olduğunu,
az miktarda başka elementler olduğunu
ve çok çok az miktarda
oksijen olduğunu görüyoruz.
Bu bizim için
ideal bir hava karışımı değil,
biz oksijen soluyoruz.
Yani yarın öbür gün
biz Mars'a yerleştiğimiz zaman,
ya Mars'ın atmosferini oksijence zengin
hâle getirmenin yollarını arayacağız
ya da basit tabirle
oksijen tüpleri ile gezeceğiz.
Üçüncü parametremiz:
Sıcaklık
Güneş'ten çok daha uzak olduğu için
Mars soğuk ve karanlık bir gezegen.
Ortalama sıcaklık -63°C.
Soğuk olduğu zamanlarda bu
-140'lara kadar çıkıyor.
Dolayısıyla,
canlılık buna dayanamayacağı için
yine o gezegende yaşamak için
sıcaklıkla ilgili de
bazı önlemler almamız lazım.
Son parametremiz de:
Büyüklük, yani hacim.
Mars, Dünya'nın altıda biri kadar.
Bu şu demek oluyor;
eğer Dünya
bir karpuz büyüklüğünde ise,
Mars da bir portakal kadar diyebiliriz.
Yani diyelim ki biz Mars'a yerleştik,
orada bir yaşam kuruyoruz.
Dünya nüfusunun sadece altıda biri
oraya yerleşebilir maksimum.
Tabii bu benim
kabaca yaptığım bir hesap.
Bunu Elon Musk'a sorduğunuz zaman,
sadece bir milyon kişinin
oraya gidebileceğini söylüyor.
Şimdi buradaki kritik soru şu:
Siz ve sizden sonrakiler,
yani çocuklarınız ve torunlarınız,
o bir milyon kişi içerisinde
olabilecek misiniz?
Tüm bu araştırmalara rağmen
Mars'ta yaşam mümkün mü,
henüz bilmiyoruz.
NASA'da bile görüş ayrılıkları var.
Bazı yetkililer Mars'ta
yaşamın mümkün olacağını söylerken,
diğer yetkililerse
"Hayır, insan sadece Dünya'da yaşayabilir.
Burada bir yaşamı olabilir.
Mars'ta bir yaşam mümkün değildir," diyor.
Net bir şey söylemek için
henüz çok erken.
Ben tabii ki
bu konuşmayı şu anda
Dünya'da yapıyorum sizlere.
Diyelim ki,
düşünelim ki yıllar geçti
ve biz bir şekilde
Mars'a gitmeyi başardık.
Böyle bir konferans salonundayız yine.
Benim gibi birisi
size bir konuşma yapıyor.
Ayağınızın ucunda bir oksijen tüpü var,
çünkü nefes almak için
ona ihtiyacınız var.
Üzerinizde sizi bütünüyle
saran termal kıyafetler var,
çünkü dışarıda sıcaklık -80°C.
Güneş gibi bir enerji kaynağımız yok.
Her yer yapay ışık,
doğal kaynaklarımız kısıtlı,
alt yapımız zayıf,
yaşayacak alanımız dar.
Ormanlar, denizler, okyanuslar yok.
Acaba o konferansta ne konuşurduk?
Bir zamanlar
büyük büyük dedelerimizin
Dünya'da ne kadar şanslı
ve mutlu olduklarını mı?
Şükür ki hâlâ Dünya'dayız.
Hiç buna şükredeceğinizi
düşünmemiş bile olabilirsiniz.
Şükür dediğimiz zaman, genelde
sağlıkla ilgili şeyler geliyor aklımıza.
Yani "Çok şükür sağlığım yerinde,
hiçbir sıkıntım yok,
sevdiklerim yanımda,"
diye düşünüyoruz.
İşte ben bunların yanına,
yaşadığım gezegenin
bana sunduğu imkânları da koydum
ve gittiğim her yerde bunu anlatıyorum.
Farkında olmadığımız
bir servetin üzerinde yaşıyoruz.
Dünya bu serveti yaklaşık iki milyon
yıldır insanlığın hizmetine sunuyor
ve insan da
Dünya'daki varlığı süresi boyunca
bu serveti kullanarak beslenmiş,
çoğalmış, gelişmiş, yayılmış.
Medeniyetler kurmuş,
teknolojiler icat etmiş.
Kendi hayatını güzelleştirmek
ve konforunu arttırmak için
hiçbir fırsatı kaçırmamış
ve tüm bunları yaparken
sınırlarını iyi tanıyamamış
ve bugün sahip olduğumuz
sorunları yaratmış.
Kısaca size o sorunlardan
bahsetmek istiyorum:
Doğal kaynakların tükenmesi.
Bugün etrafınızda gördüğünüz her şey;
içinde bulunduğumuz binalar,
yürüdüğümüz yollar,
kullandığımız eşyalar,
hepsi doğal kaynakların
kullanılması ile yapılıyor.
Düşünün ki sizin kullandığınız eşyalar,
bugün Dünya'nın bir bölgesinde
belli bir şekilde bir kazı yapılarak
hammadde olarak çıkarılıyor.
Sonra yine su ve enerji kullanılarak,
ki onlar da doğal kaynak,
bir üretim sürecinden geçiyor
ve ondan sonra da size geliyor
ve tüm bu doğal kaynaklar hızla tükeniyor.
Doğal kaynakların tükenmesinin sebebi
nüfus artışı zannediliyor,
ama sadece bu değil.
Nüfusun kentlerde artması
aslında büyük problem.
İkinci konu, iklim değişikliği.
İklim değişikliği
gelecek senaryosu zannediliyor.
Yani bir gün buzullar eriyecek,
deniz seviyesi yükselecek,
işte iklim değişikliği sorunu
o zaman bir sorun olacak.
Hayır, öyle değil.
İklim değişikliği, daha sıcak yazlar
geçireceğiz demek de değil aslında.
Bugün gördüğümüz
bütün aşırı hava olayları,
güçlü rüzgarlar,
aşırı yağışlar,
dolular,
çok sıcaklıklar,
kulaklıklara neden olan hava koşulları;
bunların hepsi
iklim değişikliğinin bir sonucu.
Geçen yaz yaşadığımız
doluyu düşünün mesela.
Biz İstanbul'da o doluyu yaşarken
Akdeniz havzasında da
kuraklık yaşanıyordu.
Kuraklık; toprağın, tarımın bitmesi demek.
Ona çok zarar veren bir şey.
Eğer tarım yoksa,
yiyecek de yok demektir.
İklim değişikliği konusunda
bir otorite olan IPCC'ye göre,
Dünya'daki ortalama sıcaklık
sanayi öncesi döneme göre,
yaklaşık bir derece arttı
ve Dünya sadece bir buçuk
derecelik bir artışı tolere edebilir.
Eğer biz bir şey yapmazsak
ve bu böyle devam ederse,
o bir buçuk derecelik artışı
2030 ile 2052 yılları arasında göreceğiz.
2030'a sadece 11 yıl var.
İklim değişikliğinin temel sebebi;
ısınma, barınma, ulaşım,
endüstriyel üretim gibi insan
faaliyetlerinde bizim fosil yakıtlarını,
yani kömür, doğalgaz, petrolü kullanmamız.
Fosil yakıtlarına
mecburmuşuz gibi bir algı var.
Hâlbuki öyle bir şey yok.
Bugün yenilenebilir enerji
hem daha kolay ulaşılabilir,
hem de daha uygun fiyatlı.
Orta Amerika'da
bir ülke olan Costa Rica bile
2021 yılında tamamiyle fosil yakıtlarını
bırakacağını açıkladı.
Bugün ülkenin elektriğinin %99'u
yenilenebilir enerjiden karşılanıyor.
Costa Rica yapabiliyorsa,
dünyanın geri kalanı neden yapmasın?
Üçüncü sorunumuz, türlerin yok olması.
Dünya'da yaşayan bütün canlılar,
bütün türler
gerekli ve önemli,
hepsinin yaşamının bir amacı var.
Ama her yıl,
30 bin tür yok oluyor;
çünkü biz yayılıyoruz,
çoğalıyoruz, genişliyoruz.
Onların evlerine kadar,
yaşam alanlarına kadar giriyoruz.
Binalar inşa ediyoruz,
şehirler inşa ediyoruz.
Köprüler yapıyoruz,
yollar yapıyoruz.
Varlıklarına saygı duymuyoruz.
Hâlbuki Dünya, bütün türlerin varlığıyla
birlikte bir düzen içerisinde dengede.
Türleri yok ederseniz,
dengeleri bozarsınız.
Şimdi bu anlattıklarımı
duymak istemediğinizi biliyorum.
Hepsi kendi başına
bir felaket senaryosu gibi,
ama konuşmamız lazım.
Şimdiye kadarki sabrınıza teşekkür ederek
şimdi duymak isteyeceğiniz
bir şey söyleyeceğim.
Bütün bu sorunların çözümleri var.
Hepsine, bütün çözümlere
biz bugün itibariyle sahibiz.
Yeni hiçbir şey icat etmemize gerek yok.
Tek yapmamız gereken, harekete geçmek.
Önce kendimizde bir değişim yaratmak,
sonra da bütün dünyanın düzeninde söz
sahibi olan insanların dikkatini çekmek.
Size bugün
bütün dünya düzenini değiştirecek,
her şeyi iyileştirecek
üç önemli tutumdan bahsedeceğim.
Eğer bu tutumları benimser ve uygularsak
inanın her şey çok daha güzel olacak.
İşte benim dünyayı kurtarma planım:
Her şeyden önce sorgulamamız lazım.
Sorunların farkında bile değiliz.
Eğer farkında olsaydık,
böyle oturmazdık.
Bugün diğer başka konularda olduğu gibi,
çevre koruma konularında da
sosyal medyada birsürü faydasız,
asılsız bilgiler dolaşıyor.
Biz iklim değişikliği konusunda
neler yapmalıyız,
enerjiyi nasıl daha verimli kullanırız,
acaba suyu tasarruflu kullanmak için
ne gibi yöntemler buluruz,
daha da önemlisi okullarda çocuklarımıza
nasıl çevre eğitimi veririz
gibi konuları konuşmamız gerekirken,
gidip bütün hıncımızı poşetten çıkardık.
Plastiğe düşman olduk.
Plastik ortadan kalkınca
bütün sorunlarımız bitmeyecek ki.
Sorgulamamız lazım.
Gerçekten önemli olan,
gerekli olan şey nedir;
bunu sorgulamamız lazım.
Kendimizi de sorgulamamız lazım.
Yaşamımızı, alışkanlıklarımızı,
tercihlerimizi de sorgulamamız lazım.
Günlük hayatınızda
daha az atık çıkarmak,
çıkan atıkları
geri dönüşüme göndermek,
israfla mücadele etmek gibi
basit değişiklikler yaparak
Dünya'ya o kadar büyük katkı
sağlayabilirsiniz ki!
Sorgulamak gerçekten çok önemli.
İkincisi, ihtiyacınızı tanımlayın.
Tüketmek demek,
doğal kaynak kullanımı demek
ve ortaya atık çıkması demek.
Bunu ne kadar az yaparsak,
o kadar iyi.
Şöyle evde eşyalarınıza bir bakın.
Kullandığınız kozmetiklere,
temizlik ürünlerine,
gardırobunuza,
buzdolabınıza bir bakın.
Eve aldığınız bütün yiyecekleri
tüketebiliyor musunuz?
Satın aldığınız bütün eşyaları
kullanıyor musunuz?
Ya da tükettiğiniz her şey
gerçekten ihtiyacınız mı?
Eğer ona bu gözle bakarsanız,
o kadar farklı şeyler ortaya çıkacak ki.
İhtiyacınızı tanımlamak çok çok önemli.
Üçüncüsü de, talep edin.
Şimdi biz günlük hayatta
bireysel olarak yaptığımız çalışmaların
etkisinin çok küçük olacağını
düşünebiliriz.
Hani
"6 milyarda 1 kişiyim ben,
dünyayı nasıl değiştireyim?" diyebiliriz.
Belki öyle,
ama bizim daha büyük tarafları
harekete geçirecek bir etkimiz var.
Şimdi bugün burada bulunan herkes
birçok markanın müşterisi, değil mi?
O markalar sizin beklentilerinizi,
isteklerinizi anlamak için
o kadar çaba sarf ediyorlar ki!
Mesela hepimizin
bildiği bir giyim markası,
geri dönüşümle ilgili bir kampanya yapıyor
dünya genelinde.
Kullanmadığınız giysileri getiriyorsunuz,
onlar belli bir tasniften geçiriyorlar.
Hâlâ kullanılabilir olanları
ihtiyaç sahiplerine veriyorlar,
kullanılamaz olanları da
belli başlı işlemlerden geçirip
onu tekrar başka bir
tekstil ürününe çeviriyorlar.
Bir gün tekrar alışverişe gittiğinizde,
onlara kasada deseniz ki,
"Bravo. Sizinle gurur duyuyorum.
Müşteriniz olmaktan gurur duyuyorum.
İyi ki böyle bir şey yapıyorsunuz."
Bu iyi bir etki yaratmaz mı?
Ya da onun rakibine gittiğinizde,
oradan alışveriş ettiğinizde,
"A firması böyle bir kampanya yapıyor.
Siz çevreyle ilgili ne yapıyorsunuz?"
diye sorsanız.
10 kişi sorsa, inanın kasadaki yetkili
bunu yönetime taşır.
Bizim bunu düzenli olarak yapmamız,
inanın çok büyük bir etki yaratır.
Benzer şekilde belediyelerden de
hizmet alıyoruz.
Mesela çöp hizmetini onlardan alıyoruz.
Çöpü uzaklaştırıyorlar.
Bağlı bulunduğunuz belediyeye
geri dönüşümle ilgili
ne yapıyorlar diye sorsanız.
Eğer bulunduğunuz evde geri dönüşüm
kutusu yoksa bunu isteyebilirsiniz,
atıklarınızı ayrı biriktirmek için
onlardan destek isteseniz.
Ulaşımı da onlar sağlıyor.
Bugün elektrikli araçların
karbon emisyonu sıfır.
Bütün ulaşım, toplu taşıma
elektrikli araçlardan ibaret olsaydı,
güzel olmaz mıydı?
Okullarda da
çevre koruma talep edebiliriz.
Çocuklarınız çevre eğitimleri alıyor mu?
Biliyor musunuz?
Yoksa talep edin.
Ya da çalıştığınız şirketlerdeki
çalışan etkinlikleri çevreci mi?
Bunu talep edebilirsiniz.
Siz sorun, isteyin,
talep edin ki bu bir konu olsun.
Dikkate alınsın, önemli bulunsun.
Eğer sorgularsanız,
eğer ihtiyacınızı tanımlarsanız
ve talep ederseniz,
inanın her şey çok değişecek.
Mars'a gitmek harika olurdu.
İnanın çok güzel bir deneyim olurdu bence.
Hele benim gibi, çocukluğu bilim kurgu
filmleriyle geçmiş birisi için
büyüleyici bir şey olurdu.
Ama orada yaşamak zorunda olmak,
bu bambaşka bir şey.
Biz bugün,
Dünya için bir kırılma noktasındayız.
Önümüzdeki 10-20 sene çok önemli.
İnsanlığın nasıl davrandığı,
neye karar verdiği,
ne yaptığı
birçok şeyin belirleyicisi olacak
ve biz bunu yapabiliriz.
Bugün modern hayat diye kurguladığımız
bu düzeni nasıl biz kurduysak,
bunun yerine
başka bir sistem inşa edebiliriz.
Hepimizin iyiliği, güzelliği,
geleceği için güzel olan bir sistem.
Bugün Dünya'nın bize değil,
bizim ona ihtiyacımız var aslında.
Tıpkı bir bebeğin
annesine ihtiyacı olduğu gibi.
Zaten bu yüzden ona
tabiat ana demedik mi?
Bizi besledi, büyüttü,
bize yaşamımızı verdi.
Şimdi bu kadar iyiliğe biraz vefa çok mu?
Tabiat anaya sahip çıkma vakti.
Yarın değil, bugün.
Belki değil, mutlaka.
Bir başkası değil;
siz,
biz.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)